hey milkshakers welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i am your host reza aslan and
i am rayne wilson hello everybody hi
reza how are you doing i'm doing all
right i had a little bit of an argument
with my uh my eldest son today had left
a bad taste in my mouth oh i'm sorry to
hear that that's that's terrible you
know is it is it me rain is it me like
kids these days am i right am i right
kids these days these days don't get me
started
like oh my god i have to be honest like
i don't remember
i just had this feeling that i was a lot
more resilient as a kid than than my
kids are i feel like nowadays like if
the slightest thing goes wrong you know
like if the if the pool is too cold
then like their day is ruined for good
they won't they won't even go swimming
they won't go anywhere forget it i'll
just just sit here by myself and and
look at the look at this guy it's like
come on man like what what happened to
resilience for kids i mean seriously
well you know it's interesting with my
son i would say that he suffered from a
lot of that and then a really
interesting thing happened that was very
transformational i think in his
characters he went to a summer camp a
good old-fashioned summer camp but it
was a month long in the friggin woods
and
there's nothing like
hiking camping canoeing rain storms cold
heat mosquitoes
to
to teach you like
resilience yeah and grit and
determination so in other words our our
childhood like the childhood that you
and i just normally had
yeah basically i mean misery lack of
food
nothing to do welcome to metaphysical
milkshake the show where we go deep we
get weird and we search for the meaning
of life along the way presented by cast
media and soul pancake
well you and i it's interesting because
you and i um you know we've talked about
this a lot we we were we came from
relatively poor upbringings you know and
um
we had our challenges but when i was a
kid
um
if i wanted to listen to music other
than a cheap you know am radio
um i wanted to buy a cassette player
well my parents didn't have money to buy
me a cassette player so that means you
go get a job
so that you earn the money for your
cassette player and not only that
you've got to earn
your 13.99 to join columbia records and
tapes
oh yeah it's 1.99 to join your columbia
records and tapes but then you've got to
fill out the form every week and you're
responsible of columbia if you forget to
fill it out and columbia sends you the
new journey you gotta pay for it
you gotta pay for that that's how they
got you
that's how they that's how they rope you
in but
there wasn't any discussion about it it
was just like if you want something
other than just
you know three pairs of pants and five
shirts if you want something beyond that
well then you're just gonna have to work
and it's gonna suck and guess what it
sucks working sucks especially when
you're 16 17 years old it sucks yeah i'd
much rather be out playing instead of
what i was doing when i was 15 years old
which was making
flyers for a paint
company and like putting them all over
town on my bike which and then now that
i actually even
like i say that out loud and i think to
myself
who decides to buy paint when they see a
flyer
like on a wall somewhere like that i
might go and buy some paint from this
place yeah well i was thinking about
buying this other brand but now that i
see this flyer crookedly stapled to this
telephone pole yeah uh next to 7 11
yeah
but but
the the larger point here i think is it
makes sense which is that you know we
spent all of our lives you and me
working our asses off you know doing
whatever it took to become successful so
that our kids
wouldn't
have to
ride a bike through town
stapling flyers you know to a wall for
minimum wage and we did it we were both
very very comfortable and we and we've
given our kids like the best life that
we i'm a lot more comfortable than you
but yeah
that's true that's true i don't have
that i don't have the residual uh checks
that you do but i do have residual
checks but they're for like 4.29 which i
have one right here
um
but
is the
drawback to that that now we have kids
who are not resilient and then even as i
say this
like the truth is is that i'm not even
sure what resilience actually even means
yeah like this does it mean suck it up
is that what that's what it means
because that's a nice thing to say to
your kids suck it up yeah
yeah i mean i like to think that it has
something to do with adaptability to
circumstances yeah it has something to
do with the virtue of determination yes
that's good that's good which could be a
positive uh
a positive attribute
but yeah i don't it's a grossly overused
word yes so
it is a grossly overused word these days
so overused so overused and it and and
it just it's kind of also become kind of
a shorthand for a kind of bullying you
know you're basically like don't be such
a wimp and it's funny because like we
were asking um our intrepid uh producer
and researcher safa to do some research
on kind of resilience and like the
history of resilience and she came up
with this nietzsche quote about
resilience this is what he says
the resilient human being is a lawyer
stop it is that racist no racist against
germans okay fine the resilient human
being is a warrior who heals the
fullness of its own soul and comes back
to life as a new person who is now above
its usual limits an ubermensch
so
when
nietzsche is telling you that like to be
resilient is to be an ubermensch like no
wonder
you and i are confused about what that
means yeah
god i i have a love-hate relationship
with nietzsche but
but this this does beg the master
question not the master race the master
question
what does not kill me makes me stronger
question mark question mark does it
really
i think we should discuss this and who
better to discuss it with than the
best-selling author steve magnus
and uh he has a new book out called do
hard things why we get resilience wrong
and the surprising science of real
toughness this is a fascinating tome
he's got a lot of interesting things to
say very excited to have steve on the
show steve is a world-renowned expert on
health and human performance he his
writing has appeared in outside runner's
world forbes sports illustrated men's
health he's been featured in new yorker
wall street journal new york times etc
etc he's also the author of the science
of running and the co-author of peak
performance and like myself
a an accomplished athlete and runner
don't laugh don't come
steve magnus welcome to the milkshake
thanks for having me it's uh our
pleasure really enjoying this book do
hard things
why we get resilience wrong and the
surprising science
of real toughness there's a lot in here
there's a lot to chew on
one of the things that i noticed from
the get go is that you're a runner
and there's a lot of runner stories
running metaphors
and
i i don't know if you knew this about me
steve but um
i was a triple jumper
wait is that true wait that is true wait
i did not know that
i feel like i've known so much about you
and i did not know that even even reza
didn't know that it was seventh and
eighth grade only yep and i did long
jump as well and i did some hurdles i
did hurdles i was a hurdler
you were a hurdler i was a hurdler i
made a good little guy though how did
you get up over those hurdles i didn't
say it was a good hurdler did you use a
pole vault
this is mostly me running from bigger
guys and jumping over things i didn't
mean like you know
like as a race or anything else i don't
know triple jump is ridiculous i don't
even remember what i did triple j is
absurd and by the way
can i like what is that why do why do
you do that why do you do that silly
little ass the greeks dance
that's right there's no real good point
but i'll tell you this the triple jump i
think it's one of the hardest events
totally
it makes no sense
and like it's actually one of the
highest events with the injuries so that
you survived that you know it's just
impressive in my book i all i remember
about it is one i went to a meet and i
came in second so i got a silver medal
at a meet so i was very excited about
that i'd never won anything having to do
with physicality before in my life but
we would have to us triple jumpers would
have to go around the track triple
jumping over and over again so it was
just the most ludicrous thing to see
there were only like three of us or four
of us and we'd like go around the track
hop hop skip jump
hop skip jump up
um over and over and over again anyways
enough enough about me we have steve
magnus
best-selling author with us here
coach
you're a you're a coach you're all kinds
of things a writer
co-founder of the growth equation you've
got your own website that's amazing that
must have cost a bundle what did you
learn about toughness and resilience
from your time as a runner and why the
centrality of
running as toughness and resilience and
did this inspire you to write the book
it you know it did because much like you
i began running track in seventh and
eighth grade
and i hated it
absolutely hated it
i was more of a soccer player but then
in high school i got really fast really
quick and my coach said like ditch
everything else you're gonna be really
good at this and i was in high school i
ran a a mile in four minutes and one
second and was like
yeah
no way four minute mile is like uh
that's that only was broken in the last
century or something like that yeah 1954
so wow it's still a hard thing to do and
as a high schooler it was really hard
and so toughness has always been the
central thing and back then i was kind
of this guy who's like my mo was i'm
gonna run until i just have nothing left
until i just puke and can't do anything
and that works really well
when you're having a good day and
everything is aligned
but what happens is when you're not
having a good day and you go and you
reach down and you're like oh i'm going
to be tough i'm going to grit it out and
that's the only place you have to go
when it's not there you just you just
fall apart and you just fail
so i think running having dealt with
that and struggled with that running is
often like one of the perfect metaphors
because what is it
you're alone in your head
with no one else to help you
feeling all this discomfort this pain
and your inner voice and dialogue often
goes to like
why in the hell am i doing this like
find a way out step in a hole like quit
and you have to navigate that and get on
the other side of it to reach your goal
or do the thing that you want to do yeah
it actually is a pretty good metaphor
now that you you bring it up because you
know
is it about being stronger or is it
about being faster or is it about just
the mental
toughness necessary to like break
through that wall and by the way as you
talk about this it occurs to me
that
uh the greatest shame
of my life was doing hurdles
uh i remember we were it was like at the
state at the state championship wait a
minute wait a minute the greatest shame
of your life really all right well i was
hoping you weren't going to bring up the
other stuff but like
amongst the greatest shames
of my life and by the way it's something
that i've never actually even like said
out loud but i'm just saying it today
because it just occurred to me is that i
remember very clearly uh it was like
seventh grade or eighth grade and it was
like state championships and i was doing
hurdles like and i was okay at hurdles
but this was like the state championship
and
uh you know we're we're running and
we're doing the hurdles and i am in last
place
and steve
i faked an injury
i prepared it i deliberately ran into a
hurdle and fell
because then this way i'd be like well i
didn't finish so i i did wasn't
technically
in last place which that reveals a lot
about your character that was just about
it
it's a whole other metaphor for the lack
of resiliency where i was just like you
know what [ __ ] it i'm gonna i'm gonna go
down there there's a lot of image
there's a lot of image management going
on there too there's a little bit of a
spin
spin zone happening listen we've talked
we've talked about that before let me
make you feel a little bit better reza
we'll we'll call this our therapy
session all right so a couple years ago
when i was getting the idea for this
book i had the opportunity to sit down
with some of the best like endurance
athletes in the world we had like people
had won new york city marathon olympians
all this stuff and it just came to me to
just say hey i want to see how many of
you have ever thought about
faking an injury in the middle of a run
and these are the best of the best
everybody raised their hand see so
everyone had thought about it not
everyone had done it some people
actually had they'd said yeah like i i
grabbed my hamstring during this race in
high school
so i think one of the things on
toughness resilience is we often would
see your story and we'd be like oh that
means you're weak
no that just means you're human because
your brain is trying to protect you and
in this case it's trying to protect you
from that embarrassment but that's a
battle we all face here's what i take
from that thank you steve uh that i'm
pretty much an olympian thank you i i
really i feel like
put it on resume i'll give you
permission practically an olympian
folks if you're a fan of this show you
know that i have uh what like
78 kids i've lost track that means
i uh don't have a lot of time for
fun and games that fabled free time that
some of you have to do things that just
do you know nothing but bring a smile to
your face i don't know what that's like
but when i do have some hard earned fun
i add some joy to my daily routine with
best fiends the puzzle adventure game
that you won't be able to put down folks
i just keep plugging away i keep killing
slugs i keep
empowering
all of my fiends i mix and match them to
best destroy the evil slugs i'm all the
way up on level 107 now it's dormant
darkness
and there's five evil slugs
on this level it's crazy it just keeps
going it's super fun i really enjoy this
game a lot best fiends is a free to
download mobile puzzle game with
thousands of exciting levels for new
adventures and challenges every time you
play there are dozens of unique fiends
to collect so you can customize your
team of fiends to defeat menacing slugs
power up your favorite fiends to new
levels for even more powerful skills and
watch them transform as they get
stronger
with offline play you'll never be
stranded without fun even if you lose
your internet connection
listen you've earned your fun time go to
the app store or google play to download
best fiends for free plus
earn even more with five bucks worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level
five that's
friends without the r
best fiends
but steve let's dig a little deeper here
i mean yes there's pain and pushing
through and you have these internal
battles but what else is it about
running that really has inspired your
you because you really have excavated
toughness and resilience and like torn
it inside out you've got science you've
got self-help you've got spirituality
psychology you really are looking at
this in a whole new way and i
appreciated the freshness
of this tome because
um in no place in this book do you say
you gotta suck it up and tough it out in
fact you had you are saying that that
way of doing things has actually been
incredibly deleterious so in your own
personal how has this affected you in
your own personal journey and struggle
yeah i mean it it's affected me in two
ways one in my own life i told you i ran
a mile in four minutes and one second in
high school but what i didn't say is i
never got better
and i think that journey on being
this close to that breakthrough you know
this close to that barrier that
everybody understands
and like really struggling with that for
a while and maybe reza you can you know
um appreciate this is almost feeling
like that traumatic embarrassing story
of like oh man i never quite got there
um so a lot of that shaped my
understanding of this and then i think
on the broader scale as well as since a
kid
or since i was like four or five years
old i've always had ocd
and ocd is a lot like running in some
interesting ways in the sense that
you have these crazy thoughts enter your
head
and then you have these urges for action
just like you might have this urge to
quit in the middle of the race or this
urge to fake an entry
and i think with ocd like if you tried
to just be like oh no this doesn't exist
i'm gonna ignore this i'm gonna push
away it just backfires it brings it back
tenfold and you really have to learn how
to like navigate or sit with it or
understand and pick apart what's real
and what's not because sometimes there
is a real danger and you really do have
an injury but a lot of times it's like
it's it's just fake it's your brain like
sounding the alarm
when you know you really don't need to
the brain telling yelling at you to quit
you know this is really fascinating
because
you talk a lot in the book about the
difference between real toughness and
fake toughness
um
and that's part of the whole thesis
right that you know we're not really
getting resilience right you know we
were talking earlier about how this is
such an overused word right especially
nowadays like
um so
what is the difference between
real toughness and fake toughness and
how does that
uh
indicate the ways in which we
don't really understand what resilience
is
yeah yeah i think it's central and i
think if we brought in all the way out i
think it's bigger than just like
resilience in athletics or in your life
i think it's something that we all
struggle with or struggle societally
with is this fake versus real because
the fake version to me is
it's all about the external it's about
the appearance of being tough
almost like the schoolyard bully who
like seems strong and powerful but
underneath they're just like insecure
and i think that's what kind of that
fake toughness or fake version is is
it's almost like let's create this
appearance of strength but underneath
there's not much and you see this again
broadening way out you see this in
society right we have
in politics we have people who like you
know
uh promote like this machoism and this
manliness and this like you know some
people some politicians have called like
you know dictators like putin as he's a
tough guy
in society we see again this this almost
like hey let's put on the external
bravado and act like we're strong
like you know
act like we have everything figured out
when the reality is we don't so that's
that's kind of like what i'm getting at
is we have this appearance without
substance and we need to turn or turn
the tables and and pay more attention to
the inner strength and the substance
which i think really matters and often
that's the quiet part that's inside and
not all the the
bravado crap that you can see on the
outside yeah you have this quote in the
book where you say real toughness is
about providing the tool set to handle
adversity it's teaching fake toughness
creates fragility responding out of fear
suppressing what we feel and attempting
to press onward no matter the situation
or demands and i like this i like this
part too real toughness pushes us to
work with our body and mind instead of
against them i think that's what does
that mean what does that mean so if you
look at how our brain and our hormones
and our biology work when we experience
something anything that causes us
anxiety or discomfort
it's it's like your brain is sounding
the alarm and says uh-oh
there's something different here and
this might be a threat
now if you resist that
what happens is you're almost affirming
that there's a threat here so for
example rayne if you're about to you
know uh do something that causes you
nerves like you know go on a show or
something and i come up to you and i say
just relax just relax
well if i say relax what does your brain
interpret like
it interprets oh man i must look super
stressed
so in the history of telling someone to
relax do they actually relax no
so what we have to do instead is work
with our but our brain and our body and
our biology
meaning like understand how it works
and then like
you know
give it the tools to be able to navigate
those difficult things if that makes
sense
you know earlier we were complaining
about our kids and how
non-resilient they they are sometimes
but i love the way that you're talking
about this as like you know true
toughness is making smart decisions in
challenging situations right it's like
you have this thing where it's like
problem solving
through obstacles not regularly faced
which then
makes the whole
thing about like ah suck it up muscle
through uh don't be a wuss don't be a
wimp you know just like
bite down and and get through it which
is
kind of a lot of what we talk about when
we talk about
you know this whole
fake epidemic of like a lack of
resilience amongst kids right the kids
these days these kids these days they
don't know what it's like they don't
know how hard we all had it and they get
everything handed to them and all that
stuff but there is something really
fascinating in what you're saying and
how you're defining resilience that is
really instructive for parents
like you know rain and me
in the way that we want to foster
these kinds of skills
um in our kids what's that what's the
best parenting advice you can you can
give uh people like us who are you know
trying to figure out how do i make my
kids more resilient without necessarily
getting you know getting into all the
the [ __ ] toxicity of it all
yeah you know it's funny and i'm not a
parent myself yet but my wife is
elementary school teacher so i i get to
see
how to manage kids pretty well and
here's the thing
is what happens is if you just kind of
put your head down and say hey just
tough it out you know suck it up etc
you're not actually learning or teaching
those kids anything
what it's really about is putting them
in in difficult situations not even
difficult like new situations allowing
them to explore and learn and giving
them that freedom to do so
and like
supporting them while they do it if
there is a little bit of truth to the
idea that you know hey like kids aren't
as resilient as they used to be
not as much as people claim but there is
a little bit to it and one of the main
reasons that is is actually because we
don't have as much unstructured play and
it's unstructured freedom for kids
nowaday
back in maybe all of our days you went
out and you played and you you know
played football on the on the playground
or what have you and you'd struggle with
winning and losing and sometimes getting
in arguments and fights and you didn't
have the adult always always there so
you had to figure out and navigate
yourself fake an injury go home
you know all that good stuff but that's
like that provides the skill set
also boredom
because you're hanging out with your
group of kids
you know and you've got till dinner time
and it's three o'clock and you don't
you're not needed till six and like
yeah what are you gonna do what do you
guys wanna do you want to go to the
7-eleven no i don't i don't have any
money you want to watch steve no
hey you want to throw a ball i don't
know and and there's something about
learning about difficulty i wouldn't say
it's anxiety but
by going through that as well
absolutely i mean it's spending it goes
back to that running piece what is
running spending time alone in your head
well what is boredom spending time alone
in your head
nowadays we often fill that almost
instantly i mean you can go to the
movies you watch people stand in line
and what are they going to do whenever
there's like a hint of boredom you grab
your phone
so you never learn how to sit with that
we'll call it anxiety although it's not
entirely that but that like tinge of
anxiety and i think with kids especially
it's learning how to sit with that and
then figure things out
you know one of the reasons actually um
if you look at why kids throw tantrums
for example in classrooms
one of the reasons they do is because
they get they feel that anxiety or that
you know the whatever is causing them
discomfort
and it's almost like a new sensation and
they don't know how to process or deal
with that emotions or those feelings so
they freak out and the way you kind of
know this is if you ask the kid what's
wrong they'll say like oh i'm sad and
they can only say i'm sad because they
don't have the vocabulary the complexity
to maybe split apart sadness from
loneliness from
frustration or anxiety
anxiety the only way we realize or
figure out how to slice and dice those
things apart is a
experiencing them and then also given
the support to kind of be like okay
here's the vocabulary behind it here's
what it kind of means and here's how you
make sense of this crazy barrage of
feelings you're experiencing
that that's so funny that reminds me
when i was first in therapy
i would say like my therapist would be
like how are you doing i'm like i feel
sad and they're like and i remember this
guy had this kind of like color wheel
that had an emotion chart
and it had i don't even remember it had
like sadness but then all these
variations of sadness like that it'd be
like can you be more specific and then
it forced you to kind of go i feel
bereft and lonely
you know you you'd have to really
articulate what was going on as opposed
to i'm mad or i'm okay or i feel good
you know to just to dig deeper a little
bit that's interesting
and you know there's fascinating and
good science behind that actually
helping
us get through not only you know
situations maybe that require therapy
but also you know resilience and
toughness
because the the other analogy i can give
you is you know maybe back in your
triple jumping days
you're going you're jumping you're doing
that two laps around the track hopping
and skipping and sometimes you'd feel a
little bit of pain but you knew that
pain wasn't an injury but if you net if
you'd never triple jump before maybe the
first time you experienced that any sort
of pain you just say oh my gosh this is
that injury but because you do it you're
able to slice and dice that apart to
understand what is good pain and bad
pain the same thing goes with all
emotions
that's incredible because i had this
friend telling me that he he recently
started being a big brother to a little
brother and the kid mostly is kind of in
a divorced home playing video games all
the time he took him on a a hike in
griffith park this kid is like 13. and
they were like halfway up the hike you
know there's pretty steep mountains up
there in in la and the kid was like oh
my god i need to stop
and he's like what's wrong he's like
i i've got an injury it's really bad
this is really bad i need i need to go
to the hospital he's like what is it
it's like my legs
what is it let me let me see did you
pull something no they're just
on fire
and it's like what it's like yeah the
muscles here like on the front of my
legs oh my god they hurt so and he
realized like
oh
he had never walked up a really
strenuous hill before in his life and
his body was going like
alert your legs are going to explode
into flames and and fall off so he had
to kind of learn like no that's called
exertion and that's
that's what happens to muscles
and he had to learn that at like 13.
crazy
yeah you know i i love that example
because
that doesn't just apply to physical
pursuits or experiences that explains to
everything and there's again good
science behind this is
when we haven't ever experienced that or
it's been a very long time it's almost
like we have this hypersensitive alarm
where the alarm goes what in the hell is
that like i've never experienced this
before my legs are on fire and burning
this must mean i'm about to die
so that's that's why it's really
important
not to you know shun away or ignore our
our feelings and not to like try and
avoid things but as you said earlier
like embrace that discomfort because the
only way we can kind of become adept and
turn that alarm down to an appropriate
level is if we've we've gone through it
before yeah so let's switch gears here a
little bit
there was a 2016 study from the national
institute of health called the dark side
of resilience
and it was showing how resilience might
negatively impact one's emotional life
their overestimating the limits of our
tolerance in adverse circumstances and
becoming an easier target for burnout
and other impairing
psychological
conditions
so i just wanted to talk a little bit
about
um what's the downside of resilience
there was a quote
here from um
veneta
srivastava forgive me if i'm saying the
name incorrectly of the don't call me
resilient podcast
and
there's some pushback on this word
remember that this was like ariana
huffington's word of the year 2020
resilience
um and
and veneta said i believe we should
always celebrate resilience
the human ability to recover or adjust
to difficult conditions but for many
marginalized people including black
indigenous and racialized people being
labeled resilient especially by policy
makers has other implications
the focus on resilience and applauding
people for being resilient make is makes
it too easy for policy makers
to avoid looking for real solutions it's
kind of like hey
don't be a victim be resilient and that
doesn't really take into account
injustices and imbalances that need to
be addressed
absolutely no i think that's a a very
good and reasonable point
you know i look at it as you know a lot
around a lot of these words there's kind
of these connotations that have just
kind of
been dumped on them over time and i
think often what happens is we use
resilience as
almost like you figure it out or like
you just get through it
and there are situations that we have to
understand that are often beyond our
control
or
situations where
getting through it might not even be the
right decision
right the right decision might be to be
not quote unquote traditionally
resilient it might be
to quit or do something else that's a
really good point and i think that's
often kind of where you know we almost
have again this negative connotation
around quitting and see it as as this
horrible thing that you can do
but in certain situations it's the right
thing so that's where i think nuances
around all these conversations and
anytime some word becomes the buzzword
what inevitably happens is then we over
emphasize that thing
and it kind of it loses some of its use
yeah there's a couple of things that i
think of i mean rain said it perfectly
the whole you know don't be a victim
talking point which strangely only seems
to apply to brown and black people and
like gay people and stuff but okay
i what drives me bananas is the whole uh
toxic positivity
thing
where it's like
um
you know like all these self-help books
about
uh
don't complain and you know turn your
tears into something wondrous and
uh you know
just all of that whole sort of facet of
self-help just drives me bananas
and also now in the post-covet world you
know
resilience is almost like this uh kind
of magical buzzword that that's supposed
to help all of humanity claw its way out
of this incredible devastation
you know that we've uh on that's been
unleashed by this
pandemic um this idea that like i mean
is it too much to say it feels like a
kind of new eugenics you know or people
are like well look you know yeah sure
millions of people died weak people fat
people
uh and you know the rest of us will be
fine we're gonna come out of this a lot
better and i'm like that sounds weirdly
like something hitler would say you know
that's a good point reza and there's two
things that come to mind first is in
researching the book i remember reading
viktor frankl the holocaust survivor um
talk about surviving the holocaust and
he said one of the things we shouldn't
do
is mistake that the survivors were the
resilient ones
and i think that's similar although on
another lever so
why is he saying that i don't get it he
said that because to him it was not it
was
about the
environment often created the situation
of who survived versus not and it wasn't
it wasn't an individual control issue
it's not that oh i survived because i'm
tough or resilient is that the
environment around me just supported me
to get be able to do this thing it's
weird
it's almost like it's adopting the
language of the nazis like well the
strong ones survive the concentration
camps
exactly and i think that's that's often
kind of you know it's yeah it's just
very harrowing and wrong and i think the
other thing on this
is that
resilience
is so environmental
and maybe to go back to that idea of i
said hey
certain people have a more sensitive
alarm well if you look at how people
were upbringing and raised and if they
were raised in low socioeconomic status
there's actually some good data that
shows that their brain like reaction to
certain kinds of threats
is very hypersensitive why because the
brain was preparing for the environment
that it was in
which was often one of hey i don't know
where my next meal is gonna come from i
need to be in kind of survival mode
so of course you're gonna have maybe a
hyperactive stress response
and that's not through anything that
that kid or you know now grown adult did
it's just part of the environment that
you know he was in so i think often we
we almost think of resilience and think
of it as like this individual hardiness
when we need to zoom way out and be like
hey everything
from our environment from our societal
narratives from the culture that we we
you know inhabit all of those play a
role and it's not just like hey i'm
going to be tough today sometimes you
don't have that choice
it's funny the um
i was watching this trailer for a new
documentary about dr gabor mate who is a
guest on this show and i think we're
going to have him back this
fall just one of the most brilliant
human beings who talks about trauma and
addiction but he draws
parallels into like how society works as
a
traumatized addicted society right and
he said in this trailer and it was so
great it was like you know we spent our
whole lives like trying to fit into
civilization that's our goal how do we
fit into civilization how do we be
successful and happy and well balanced
and have relationships and a career and
get an education in
quote unquote civilization but
what if civilization is broken what if
civilization is rotten and corrupt and
trying to fit into it
trying to
uh
be successful in navigating something is
not good for you because civilization
doesn't take care of us it doesn't
provide for us in the way that it could
in the way that it should so
i'm sorry rain so you mean like
why not opt out
no we're just saying we need to fix what
civilization is like everyone just buys
like oh
you know doing it 15 years of things
right we do 12 years of school and then
we do four years of college and then we
try and get a job and then you try you
know make sure you find that
relationship and you know you've got to
earn this much money and then you've got
to buy a house and like and you've got
to be functional and you've got to find
your community and your friends and
you've got to be healthy and you've got
to have great mental health and physical
health and well-being it's like but this
system is this kind of add habit trail
um
and it's it's it's really unhealthy so i
i don't i don't know what this has to do
with
my next question but
i it was also making me think about this
um
in in therapy i i diamond therapy again
um i did this thing for a while called
gestalt therapy and um
it's really interesting
because what it is is it's saying that
inside every person's head you have all
these different voices
you have the
demanding parent and you have the whiny
child and you have the scared boy and
you have the rebellious teenager and you
have you know
the the naysayer and you you know you
have all this chorus of voices so that
when you can distinguish these voices
then you start to have conversations
with them so if it's the disapproving
parent then you start to have a
conversation with that part of yourself
that's the disapproving parent that's
the voice is like you can never get this
right you're always gonna get this wrong
you're always gonna [ __ ] up you're
you'll never amount to anything and you
and you'd be like literally like why do
you say that well because i see that
well
you know you could do it by writing this
down in a journal or you can literally
play act with an empty chair and you
could play both roles
and
i was struck by
the amount of
uh real estate in your book about the
voices in your head you have a whole
chapter on it but it kind of is a theme
that runs throughout so what is this
these voices in your head and i don't
want to say mastery but learning to deal
with the voices in your head what does
that have to do with resilience yeah i'm
so glad you brought up that example
because if you look at the latest
psychology it's spot-on
is we all or most of us have these
conversations and this this kind of like
inner battle with these various voices
and i often think of it as like this
angel and devil on your shoulder
and you're kind of stuck in the middle
navigating
and i think traditionally what we tell
ourselves is like oh just ignore the bad
ones or push them away and just amplif
amplify the good ones
and that again often doesn't work
because whenever we push or resist
something
that voice often comes back 10 times
stronger
so instead to me it's learning how to
communicate with them
meaning like understanding what voices
are the ones you should listen to in
that moment versus what voices are maybe
the ones that like hey you might
acknowledge are there but it's like your
crazy aunt or uncle ranting on facebook
and you just need to scroll on by
right and in the only way you learn how
to do that
is essentially spending time in those
you know gestalt therapy is a great
example but spending time like figuring
out okay should i listen to this how do
i talk to this how do i get out of this
and then the other thing that i think is
really important is
that we have these voices that are often
what i'd call
kind of passive they come upon us
they're kind of placed upon us almost it
feels like and then we have our active
self which is
you're in command of your self-talk
and what the science and psychology
clearly shows is that
if you shift the way that you talk to
yourself
you can um shift how you deal with that
uncomfortable moment so to give a quick
example there's some fascinating work
that says
you know simply if i change from using
you know first person to third person or
second person
the second and third person creates
what's called psychological distance and
it's almost like your brain interprets
it as if it's advice coming from a
stranger so it'll listen to it more than
if you're just sitting there you know
um
talking in first person to yourself
that's fast i totally believe that to be
true
like it i know it sounds like a small
thing but it does create this weird
psychic shift in the brain
it does and one other thing that i think
is fascinating if you ever watch sports
like tennis
you often see them talking to themselves
out loud before they're about to surf
the reason they do that is again some
preliminary research shows the same
thing as it creates distance your brain
almost it hears another voice which is
your own and it says oh i better listen
to that almost like it's coming to
friends right do you do that a lot sorry
sorry he brought up tennis i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go that way because i knew it
so this is it's fascinating so i don't
know i watched the wimbledon final this
last weekend which was fantastic and
curios has these explosions against the
umps and to his box and and he has to do
that to blow off steam i wish he could
find a healthier way to do it but i
don't know if you know nick curios but
he's kind of the notorious bad boy of
tennis and he has those kind of
eruptions but yeah people
they talk to themselves but what i read
interestingly enough in the seminal book
zen in the art of tennis is that
um
positive self-talk doesn't help
so this is really interesting thing it
goes right in hand with what you're
saying if you're playing tennis and you
hit it in the net and then you go
come on you could do better you'll get
it next time hit it over the net next
time
it doesn't make you any better at
hitting it over the net next time so
what does work it's kind of like the
talk is
oh
you hit down you hit across the ball
really think low to high next time you
get one of those shots
think low to high and then that helps
like you're making adjustments you're
coaching yourself you're you're talking
about like oh you're like oh the the
opponent is always hanging to his left
because he doesn't like his backhand you
know let's try and hit some sharp angles
over there like
okay just focus on the ball this next
button this next point focus on the ball
just keep your eye on the ball like
those are the things that actually help
you as opposed to come on you can do it
you got this
steve you you've completely derailed
this conversation by bringing you up
tennis well done
hey
i'm sorry
should we go back to hurdles
i'd love to hear some more or more of
reza's hurdle stories i think that was
my one story so ray no i love the tennis
stuff because it's such a mental game as
well
and you know the way i like to think of
it is your self-talk or your inner
dialogue is almost like you're
commanding your brain what to pay
attention to
so if you say like you know hey don't
hit it in the net net this time or
you know you've got this what are you
telling your brain to pay attention to
the mistake you just made or
saying oh i got this well what what does
that do that's not a command that's very
nebulous but if you sit there and you
give it instructions it's almost like
your brain goes okay here's my
instructions i'm going to shift my
attention to this and leave what just
happened behind which is the whole point
that's also why curios like blows up why
does he blow up he has to blow off that
steam so that he can leave that point
behind and not let it linger because if
for him if he just encapsulated it it
would probably linger and then affect
the next shot the next shot the next
shot
so the working title of this episode of
metaphysical milkshake is what doesn't
kill you makes you stronger
you know now that we've kind of gotten
this understanding of what resilience is
not
which i think has been very very helpful
to me not just as a a person but also as
a man and also as a father
how about what about some advice about
like
how you can
actually
foster
resilience in yourself and in society
you talk in the book about the four
pillars of toughness can you take us
through that yeah sure so briefly the
four pillars are pretty simple is number
one is ditch the facade and embrace
reality which kind of gets at something
we've been hinting around at which is
resilience isn't about you know kind of
faking your way through it or like
convincing yourself you got it
it's not bravado it's facing the reality
of the situation and sometimes the
reality of this situation is this is
going to be really freaking difficult or
this sucks but when we face that reality
and we have an accurate appraisal of
what we're going to face and then an
accurate appraisal of what we can handle
then research shows again our bodies
aligned and it has a more productive
stress response versus what we call kind
of a threat or freakout response which
tends to
send us spiraling out of control
and the second is listen to your body
which is again something that we've
talked about a little bit which is
your your feelings your emotions they're
messengers they're not dictators they're
messengers that we need to speak the
same language of as we talked about
before and then the same goes with your
voice it's not about ignoring it it's
about realizing how to make your inner
voice more productive
and then the third pillar is respond
instead of react
which is essentially if you look at the
research and you look at what the
world's best performers do
when they're in the middle of a a very
stressful situation
it's not hitting the alarm button and
then just going and finding the the
safest or the quickest solution that's
reacting responding is almost creating
the space so that you can navigate that
situation what i like to think of here
is the the people in the special forces
where i talked to is that essentially
when they're in a survival situation
it sucks your brain is trying to drag
you out to survive and it's going crazy
and you have to find something to grasp
onto that
allows you to stay in that moment and
create the space to do the things that
you need to do
and then the last pillar is what i call
transcend discomfort which is
essentially getting at that point that
we briefly talked about which is
our environment matters a lot
and if you want people to be tough then
you have to create the situation where
they feel supported and where they feel
like they can take risks maybe even fail
and still come back and do their job
again and then the last part of that
transcending is
it's not avoiding discomfort
it's about finding meaning and that
discomfort often
which is whenever we go through tough
things the best thing we can do is learn
how to process that instead of avoid it
and process often means making sense or
finding meaning in it
well that's just fantastic uh steve
this has been such a delightful
conversation i love those four pillars i
got a lot out of this book this has
really it's really helped me reshape my
own personal
relationship to tough even just what
you're saying right there like if you
want to promote toughness
create an a warm nurturing loving
environment so that people can take
risks that is so antithetical to what
the american idea of toughness or
resilience
is that's really beautifully researched
and very well said
thank you for coming on the milkshake
and it was just a delight to have you
here
oh thanks so much guys i really
appreciate it
wow fascinating so many cool concepts
yeah i really i feel tougher do you feel
tougher well i hate that word tough you
know even in his
title
the real toughness i mean
do i feel
more adaptable flexible resilient i i do
a little bit i think i've learned a few
things actually some of these episodes i
do
i'm not saying i know it all but i don't
really come out the other side feeling
like i have new information in some way
but this one i really do there's like
some things for me to think about but
i was i guess it brought up for me reza
like are there things in your life that
you feel that you could
utilize some of these tools to make your
life better to make yourself more
resilient what are some struggles and
obstacles that you're up against that
you could kind of use some of these
tools to
i won't say combat but to
undertake
well i'll tell you i'll tell you what
was probably the biggest takeaway for me
it was just kind of a line that he it
was almost a throwaway line when we were
talking about you know our kids when he
was like
you know
resilience isn't about sucking it up and
and pushing
through that sometimes
you know when you're in that place that
i sometimes find my son in
that that's the body that's his brain
telling him
something is wrong something is off pay
attention that it's really just kind of
a sign of of anxiety or fear
maybe
and that maybe me sort of yelling at him
to like get over it
is not the best way to deal with fear
and anxiety so i really like that i i
really like this idea that when i'm
confronted with
what i view
as a lack of resilience in my kid
that maybe what i should do is
switch
the way that i'm looking at it and
instead think to myself oh there's
something wrong there's a there's a fear
here there's an anxiety here there's a
there's an issue here that and that the
lack of resilience is a symptom of that
thing instead of the problem itself that
that really that hit me what about you
what about you any uh yeah yeah yeah i
think
a couple things one is i think you're
exactly right like creating for our
children the sense i love that idea of
like creating a a safe environment
almost for failure actually is what
breeds toughness you know
it's support it's mutual support that
allows you to feel safe enough to try
try new things not that i was parenting
this way anyway but you know any kind of
like berating and kind of like suck it
up and push through i don't know if that
i don't know if that works yes i don't
know
i mean
if it worked i guess you'd do it but i i
don't know if it works and i think for
me you know
one of the things i still struggle with
is just my career as an actor you know
it's it's really hard uh hollywood is
one of the hardest worst places to to
make a career it's also one of the best
and you get paid really well and i've
been on some great tv shows and some
great movies and some great podcasts
but
so much is out of your control i mean
it's just
so much just spiraling in every which
way and decisions being made by hundreds
of people that are looking at this kind
of like stock market of actors and ups
and downs and
comparisons and envy and who's hot and
who's not and and
to kind of lovingly detach my ego from
that and to recognize this is the
reality he kept talking about like
seeing the reality of it like the
reality of the situ here's the reality
of the situation it's like there's very
few people who really know what they're
doing everyone's kind of mad capped
scared out of their asses trying to make
money in a in a business that makes no
sense
and
if you recognize it as that then then my
own ego
won't get bruised by uh decisions being
made about the rain wilson brand and and
business yeah this has been a lifelong
struggle but i think i can continue to
learn more resilience around that what
about you milkshakers
is there something in your life that
you have a hard time struggling with
dealing with do you have
a story about
um
resilience or the lack thereof let us
know
you can find us on social media at reza
aslan and rainwilson on twitter at
metamilkpodcast and on instagram
metaphysicalmilkshake let us know your
life's big question let us know uh how
you deal with resilience in your life uh
we'd love to hear from you and in fact
we have yes a bunch of free copies of
steve magnus's
do hard things the first five people to
leave a positive review i guess it could
even be a negative review i don't care
just a review on apple podcasts take a
screenshot send it to metaphysical cast
media.com that's cast with a k the first
five we hear from are going to be sent
a copy of this fantastic book
free books i love giving away free books
please
participate also make sure to subscribe
to the metaphysical milkshake youtube
channel and watch us having these
scintillating conversations
all right guys see you next week and in
the meantime
suck it up
suck it up
dingbats metaphysical milkshake is
executive produced by rayne wilson reza
hasland and colin thompson it is
produced by safa samazadeh yazd harris
lane mick dimaria hashem self and dj
lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
hey rayne uh while i was waiting for you
to come back from the bathroom i
researched the triple jump in ancient
greece and it turns out that they didn't
actually do the hop skip jump until much
later when they were clothed
which if you think about it makes so
much nobody
nobody wants to see
someone doing a naked triple jump no one
wants to see anyone doing a triple jump
at all ever but then you throw in nudity
and like all the bouncing around
ridiculous ways
it's just oh it's so slappy
yeah no that's it's definitely best
clothed hey thanks for watching you guys
for more fantastic videos just like the
one that you watch please subscribe to
our youtube channel thank you